[Music]
you have a lot in the works but one
being a really long awaited sequel
Maleficent playing a villain what can
you tell me that your character and
working opposite Angelina Jolie the
Queen tell all you want to do is work
with people that can improve you as an
actor and people that you respect and
you know Angelina Michelle Pfeiffer this
is a phenomenal cost ratio tell you know
this is Elle Fanning this is a people
that I respect and I've been watching
for years and have a human respect for
as well as a professional respect other
than that it's Disney Mass that's great
fun you know it's finally something that
my um my nieces and nephews and my
children can enjoy and watch instead of
this you know foul-mouthed violent dark
stuff I usually do ET spoke to the
Maleficent sequels villain ed skrein at
the premiere of his new movie in
darkness was a woman in the anime oh
she's blind
what was it like kind of for the
physicality of acting opposite of a
woman who is what the character is blind
it was interesting you know again going
into the rehearsals it was unique him in
the regard that you know usually your
actor is giving you everything with
their eyes the eyes tell the thousand
stories so for them to not look you in
the eyes is a it was an interesting
dynamic but after that it became doubly
interesting so you know there was this
invisible wall between Markham Sofia as
characters and I was able to study her
aesthetics to try and break down that
wall in my mind you know so it is an
interesting onion a very interesting
situation and I've never had that
dynamic with an actor before and and you
know you just want to be challenged as
an actor all the time and that was
challenging
[Music]